okay now are you what's termed a second
screener do you know what a second
screen is watching TV with an iPad or
phone your hand and doing something at
the same time are on you are a second
screen I am a little bit apparently this
is on the decline it was thought that
more people are doing this but not
researchers and suggest that this may
not be the case Oliver Smith is an
expert in all of this he is a reporter
with the memo the metal is an online
technology mine I knew that because I
was able to sort of do that while I was
reading that all abided and what do you
think about two screens for your viewing
I mean we probably have a lot of
problems this one my 14 year old he said
Stein dad coming watch this movie and
then it never looks at it he says he is
looking at it but he's doing something
else but what's your view absolutely I
mean since 2007 since the iphone since
the ipad smartphones tablets it's so
popular now to have all these devices
while we're watching TV we're on
facebook we're on twitter or an
Instagram it's not just the younger
generations it's our generations as well
yeah this is so popular now but this new
research suggests something otherwise it
suggests that the youngest generations
are starting to turn away from these
screens maybe they're a bit bored with
them maybe they they want to focus more
on what they're watching but that seems
to be the trend on the cutting edge at
the moment and with this concern you in
any way I mean a lot of people would say
hallelujah thank you for this
concentration at last I think maybe not
concerning but I think it's interesting
to see how behavior is changing you know
maybe we are starting to say whoa we've
got too many screens too many devices we
need to put them aside focus on the TV
while watching great drama Game of
Thrones Walking Dead zoos me could I
stop you out there I'd like to go over
to our game of thrones special
correspondent here illness well it's
coming back as you probably know in less
than a week's time and I would argue
that watching something like Game of
Thrones or walking dead is actually
better if you're kind of engaging with
people who are also watching it the same
time like five Twitter or or something
else it actually adds to the enjoyment
in a way I couldn't agree more last year
game of thrones was the most tweeted
about show on TV I think it was 16
million tweets
sent all about Game of Thrones last year
and it's coming back this week and I'm
sure we'll see even more tweets sent
about it and if you're watching some
like the Eurovision Song Contest it's
positively brilliant if you are double
screening because it's so funny to hear
what do you ever say and sport can be
you saying that's brilliant sport can be
quite brutal you've got to be careful on
that sports another and area where where
this happens and then but what you're
saying is there's not my new generation
coming in to do this well that's what
the research teams to indicate another
report from accenture said that
eighty-seven percent of people still use
a second screen but maybe what we're
seeing is a gradual decline slow down on
that top end whereas before it is
growing so rapidly there are there are
different types of double screening they
want live there are types of double
screen where you're watching something
say on the TV and you're on your other
screen talking about what you're
watching on TV so your source of light
engaging with it ee but then you know my
kids will be watching something
completely different with that's a
neatly different noise and sort of
watching something is that sort of
double screen i don't agree with it but
it happens if you watch The Walking Dead
there's an app you can run to to go
along with the program you can vote on
the characters who might survive who
might not make it this episode pretty
much everyone wait whereas there's the
other second screening which is watching
something completely different you're on
Facebook your Twitter you're not really
paying attention so I think it's
important to make the distinction
between those two types of screens well
I'm watching another screen which tells
me Oliver our time is up thank you very
much and dates they're reporting on
those trends Oliver Smith is a reporter
with the memo and online technology
magazine we will hit the brake Jackie
after that well if you are less to find
could you bear to watch this